so you want to go to grad school but you
aren't sure whether it's worth it the
first and probably most important
question to ask is can you even get a
job with that degree for example 15
percent of law school grads can't get
work so if your prospects are bad start
again that JD might not be worth it if
you think you can land a job the next
step is to calculate what your years at
grad school will cost tuition textbooks
living expenses upgrading that futon to
a real bed if you need to take out a
loan consider how long it might take to
pay it off and add the interest of that
total federal loans do have low interest
rates but remember student loan debt can
never be forgiven even if you're
bankrupt okay so you crunch the numbers
now will your salary improve because you
have a graduate degree there are many
websites that offer these salary
comparisons but when estimating your
future paycheck make sure it's on the
conservative side because it's better to
be safe than sorry
no difference in salary don't do it
salary looking better awesome
but with those new student loan payments
are you sure that that increase is
enough no don't do it
yes great but another thing to consider
is how your retirement nest egg or
future investments might be affected if
you are earning you aren't saving more
student debt may mean you'll have to
stall on buying that dream house
or finally upgrading that Queen to a
king but don't forget to weigh that all
up against some of the pros of grad
school like making connections for
future jobs reach out to the recent
alumni and ask about the program will
the skills you learn there truly make
you better at your job
or help you skip a few rungs on the
career ladder if yes nice send in that
application
I'll bet you didn't know that in the 70s
high school sex education was arguably
more progressive than it is